Let's Roast!
- Nicole used to be
a competitive skier.
That's why she's so good
at taking double blacks.
[groans and laughter]
- Uh, Andy was molested
as a young schoolboy.
He graduated top of his class
and bottom of his teacher.
[groans and applause]
- It was my babysitter,
and at least I got something
out of a hookup.
- Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
- Nicole fucked the booker
at the Comedy Store,
and the only thing
she got on the wall
was her face
pressed against it.
[crowd exclaims]
- I'm so sorry.
- Andy looks like a slave owner
who would be really bummed
if his slaves didn't want
to hang out with him.
[laughter]
- That's not
how slaves work.
They don't have a choice.
- Whoa!
- Last joke.
- You guys, Nicole's
actually pretty excited
about the Trump win,
because when he starts deporting
illegal immigrants,
she'll get more shifts
at the Costco
she passes samples out at.
- Andy just hates Costco
'cause his ex-wife was
fucking guys in bulk.
[laughter]
Andy and his ex-wife had
an open marriage.
That's a hipster term for,
"I can't make my wife come."
[laughter]
[glass shatters]
- That'll do it, everybody.
That's the last battle
of the night.
Make it loud!
Nicole.
Andy.
[cheers and applause]
Whoo!
- Whoo!
- A lot of dirty laundry aired
in this one.
- Definitely the vicious battle
of the night.
Give it up for these two.
- Yeah.
[cheers and applause]
- So funny.
- That was great.
Andy is super funny.
I think--he's my homey,
and his standup is so funny,
but I thought
you cleaned him out, Nicole.
I thought
you took him all the way.
Yeah, no doubt, yeah.
Sorry.
I mean, it was funny.
Both of them were funny.
Some good jokes--
double blacks was really funny.
But I thought that, Nicole,
every one was--
it was that fire,
and I'm not just saying that
as another Jew.
I'm saying that
as a fan of you.
- Love Jew.
Love Jew.
- Although it does not help
that Andy looks like
what Hitler jerked off to.
- My first credit.
[laughter]
- That was a good--
I enjoyed that battle.
Andy, I appreciate
that you're wearing
the white-guy starter kit.
- Yeah.
- [laughs]
- I liked Nicole
in this one, Andy.
- I get it.
- I did like your meanness
and everything,
but, you know,
she counterpunched
on one of your jokes,
on the Costco joke,
and that was like,
"Whoa, what the fuck?"
That was it right there.
- No, that was great.
As a comic,
I realized, like,
"Oh, she must have really worked
at Costco at some point
to have had such a quick"--
'Cause I was like, "Damn,
she's a fucking super genius
if she didn't work
at a Costco."
- I work at a Costco.
- Currently, yeah.
- Currently.
- That was
a great callback, Nicole.
I could see how hard you worked
on this.
Andy.
- Yeah.
- You seem like you're gonna
fucking take out a gun
and kill us all.
- No, no.
I talk about my ex-wife
fucking guys onstage already.
- Andy just looks like that.
- Yeah.
[laughter]
I'm very low
on the spectrum.
- I know you're a great
"Roast Battle" fan, Andy.
You're a super-funny comic,
and thank you for doing this.
- Thanks, man.
- But I do think Nicole--
I got her an almost perfect
score tonight.
So you owned him tonight.
- Yeah!
- Congratulations.
- Yo, winner
of the last battle of the night,
funny girl Nicole Aimée!
[cheers and applause]
Hug each other!
- She was just solid.
She had great jokes
all around,
and I got--I got nervous,
you know.
I'm not used to being
around women, so...
- Yo.
- I'm not used to being
around vegans.
- [laughs]